Farley is more than just cute he's a
fighter
when he was born his mother a first-time
mom wasn't around to take care of him
keepers found him just hours after birth
cold dirty and hungry when we first got
our look at Farley we were mostly
concerned about two things
his early poor nutrition he had not been
fed by the mother and the fact that he
was hypothermic or had a low body
temperature although nursery keepers
here had never hand raised a red panda
before it didn't take long to settle on
a successful formula that's enough
that's enough so still challenging Phil
nerve-wracking but he's doing well we're
very pleased with his progress so far
everything seems to be doing well and
we're just keeping her fingers crossed
but Farley's problems weren't over just
yet at only three weeks his once
voracious appetite began to shrink and
his breathing became heavy keepers
rushed him to the zoo's hospital he had
a very advanced and very severe
infection going on inside of his body
and that he was indeed struggling for
life for a while it was touch-and-go
the massive infection required weeks of
heavy antibiotics and regular tube
feedings soon Farley was well enough to
move back to his home at the nursery and
ready to take the next step this change
right now is just to try to get him to
be a better climber he's doing well
really well exploring what he needed
next in life was at the Rosamond Gifford
Zoo in Syracuse New York another hand
raised red panda named Vinci it's very
important for red pandas as as
youngsters to have playmates
so that they don't bond so completely
with human beings as you can see they're
really really active and they really
like each other's company and I like to
play and sleep together now I think the
the essential thing about Farley that
sets him apart is his struggle was very
difficult he never lost his will to
survive and the personality that emerged
from those struggles was one that was
surprisingly affectionate and playful
and he was just a great guy
[Music]